ten studio dan greenawalt
2015 marks the 10-year anniversary of
the 42 series and in the decades since
its first release over 25 million fans
have experienced the automotive world of
forsyth between the return of Porsche
and forts Orizon to our partnership with
fast and furious and the debut of the
fort the show stealing Ford GT 2015 has
already been a great year for racing
gamers but this year is far from over on
the fifteenth of September racers all
over the world will get their hands on
forts of motorsport 6 the most beautiful
the most technically advanced and the
most comprehensive game we have ever
built in four to six you'll race over
450 forts evista cars twice as many as
any other racing game this generation
and every car includes working cockpits
doors and headlights as well as full
damage and customization armed with your
favorite cars 426 world-famous
destinations all built to the highest
level of detail and realism and through
the power of Xbox Live compete in epic
24 player races on dedicated servers
here only ranked leagues deliver fast
and fair competitive multiplayer and in
leagues you'll be grouped into ranked
divisions based on both your speed and
your professionalism every week new
events are created for each division top
racers against top racers for top prizes
in the new career feel the
claustrophobia of racing by headlight
alone in the utter blackness of night
and the danger of competing in the rain
as tires hydroplane across physically
based 3d puddles this is as real as it
gets let's take a closer look
xbox one exclusive time we race rain or
shine Josef Newgarden is a ferocious
competitor he just won in toronto while
racing in wet weather conditions having
his perspective really helped us deliver
an experience that speaks to players of
all types racing in the wet everyone
calls it the great equalizer because
it's the toughest conditions you're ever
going to run it when we decided to do
rain we wanted to do it in an impactful
authentic way the brake lights the spray
being surrounded by cars the way that
the water shears off cars in front of
you a windshield wiper in your face it's
perfect we have a hundred and forty
eight unique drivable surfaces rumble
strips grass gravel cement tarmac all of
them had to feel unique there's a lot of
different areas of the track that you
have to make sure are correct each with
different values for wet and dry
we approached researching this in the
most authentic way we could going
through old race footage doing our
measurements on the track itself we're
able to recreate where every single
puddle was placed I Drive multi-million
dollar simulators and none of them that
I've experienced have had wet conditions
built into their model so for Ford said
to be at the cutting edge of that is is
pretty cool and all rain is running at
the speed of simulation at 1080p and 60
frames a second with 24 cars on track
all of this wouldn't be possible without
the Xbox one
Forza Motorsport 6 has reached a new
level they are always pushing the
boundaries that I think they always
deliver